he has an interesting a fascinating
article that he penned for the athletic
called an 18-game NFL regular season
shouldn't be dismissed so quickly all
right Ross Tucker I'm all ears how are
you rust rich I am fantastic always good
to talk with you and yeah and to be
clear by the way rich right from the
start of this as a fan and now a member
of the media I wouldn't be in favor of
18 games I kind of like it the way it is
now if they were gonna make any edition
I've said it for a long time I like the
idea of a 17th game and additional buy
weeks you get 19 weeks of television
inventory and that 17th game would mean
every team plays one neutral site game
but if I were still playing in the
league I would really want the NFLPA to
strongly consider an 18th game and
really an 18 game season you look at the
math behind it mess hall where the Wall
Street Journal Rich said it would be an
extra 2.5 billion dollars and right now
the players get 47% of that I actually
think that'll probably go up a little
bit but right now 47% of that would be
one point one eight billion dollars a
year which if you take the 1,700 guys in
the NFL or whatever that's over $600,000
per player per year that would be
injected in a salary cap so I'm not
saying they should do it I'm just saying
if I was you know a young guy in the
league and I know this would start in
2021 I would want them to seriously
consider it
well I mean what about the idea though
Ross that Dee Smith forwarded that a you
know a coal miner could make more money
with more hours in the coal mine but
it's not maybe I'm paraphrasing the
healthiest idea I mean there's no
concern on that front well so first of
all it's tough to know Wendy says
something if he really believes that or
if he realizes that the 18 game season
is up
the owners really really won and so he's
just posturing and using that as a
bargaining chip
I do think and I understand the idea
that you know at some point enough is
enough I guess I look at though rich and
I mean the Patriots play 18 or 19 games
every year and it doesn't seem to be
bothering those guys that much I mean
they're they still go to the Super Bowl
of the year after that and the year
after that even though they're playing
18 or 19 games every year meanwhile
twenty teams would only play 18 and
that's it so I just don't know that we
have the data to say well 18 games are
gonna be so many more injuries and it
can be so much worse for the players and
and health and safety plus the other
thing is and I thought this is
interesting part of the Wall Street
Journal article where it said that the
NFL piays internal calculations suggest
that if you did that the average career
would go from three point three years to
two point eight years but what I guess
my argument from a health and safety
standpoint would be rich if you said
okay Ross you know I played seven years
six the counter for my pension to stuff
if you said okay Ross you're not gonna
be able to have seven years you're gonna
play five instead but the money's the
same I would rather have done that so
it's two more games for those five years
but I have two years less of training
camp and all those practices I mean
people are talking about what two more
games would mean if you get the same
money and you're playing a year or two
less of football what about that part of
the health and safety that you're
getting the same money but playing a
year or two less on your body Ross
Tucker former NFL offensive lineman
right here on the Rich Eisen show you're
beginning to make sense which is pissing
me off Russ Ross I don't like this at
all I don't like it at all well you also
rich you also get the money earlier
right I mean time value money have you
said okay Ross you can get you're gonna
get three million bucks in your career
you can either play you know five years
and play 18 games or seven years and
play 16 games I'd say five years and
eight
in games that's two more years left to
train and get everything I mentioned
plus I'm getting the money earlier right
so time value of money I can invest that
money earlier plus okay then I'm 26 and
I'm able to go out and get into my next
career or what have you
rather than 28 I mean there's a lot of
benefits the negatives are those years
would be a little bit tougher I mean by
the end of the season I know I was
always hurting and I was always kind of
happy to be honest with you when the
season was over I mean did I want to
make the playoffs
yeah but man that that feeling when that
last game is over is really really good
and at the time if you asked me in
December hey do you want to play two
more games I would say no but if you
said it's two more games X I think most
of the rank-and-file kind of like I was
would say yeah I don't I'm not feeling
great right now if we're gonna give me
two more games X let's do it
well I mean again you're you're putting
it in the box of of just looking at it
from the point of view of it wouldn't be
so bad for the player health and safety
issue that you're actually making more
money etc but the practicality of it and
I think that that's where you that's why
you started your segment here Ross
Tucker that you're saying as a fan you
don't like it because with 18 games if
you're gonna do it I would think that
that would come hand in hand with an
expansion of the playoffs eligible teams
to that you would now with two extra
weeks of the regular season they
wouldn't just keep it for the same
number of playoff teams because if
you're gonna be already expanding it
you're gonna be expanding you want to
expand the amount of playoff games as
well I mean that would be the the
Bonanza the mother lode and the season
would last deep into February I don't
think I like that at all I'm you know I
know that I'm talking against the the
the revenue generators that are
generating the revenue for my NFL
Network paycheck I just wouldn't like it
though I don't think it would be good
for the sport yeah my concern rich
would be how diluted the rosters might
be by the time you get to the playoffs
you know last year we actually had a
pretty good year in terms of quarterback
hell yeah
but there's always those years where
like the Cardinals make the playoffs but
like Ryan Lin he's their quarterback yet
whatever if you added two more games the
negative in my mind the concern is you
have to account probably for one more
offensive lineman being down and that
might not sound like much but if you get
to the seventh or eighth offensive
lineman for teams it materially impacts
things you know I'm also averse to
change naturally I kind of like the
cadence of the season you know the
weekend after Labor Day done by New
Year's we have the playoffs Superbowl
first Sunday in February I like that so
that's why I say if they really really
are trying to get more money out of this
because you know the players don't have
that much to offer the owners to try to
get concessions like they're not going
to strike so to actually get more of the
revenue the players have to give up
something I think what they could give
is they could give another game I like
the idea of you know a 17th game I told
you everybody plays a neutral site game
that way nobody's losing a home game
rich to play in London or Mexico City or
Munich or whatever I love the idea being
a Pennsylvania kid of the Eagles and the
Steelers you know playing a Penn State
things like that I just think they could
generate a lot of buzz if every team
played one neutral site game that way
you're getting 19 weeks of the TV money
but you're only asking the guys to play
one more week and no fan bases are
actually losing a home game what would
be what would that's interesting Ross
let's just stroll down that rabbit hole
real quick what do you think the fan
base split would be there in Happy
Valley what do you think it would be oh
man literally have steelers and eagles
you think it would be amazing well first
of all you know it is I mean these
college stadiums you went to Michigan
they would sell that out in a heartbeat
and it would kind of be reminiscent rich
of
SEC Championship game so I've been on
the sidelines for the SEC championship
game the last couple years and when it's
half the crowd is Alabama and half the
crowd is Georgia which I've been to a
couple Super Bowls but I'm telling you
last the SEC championship game last year
that was the most electric atmosphere
for a football game I've ever been in I
mean there's just something to that the
tension when there's the fan bases like
that and I think it would be pretty
split now Philadelphia is a bigger city
and there are more Eagles fans but man
the Steelers just that brand of the
success going back to the 70s I think it
would be pretty pretty much 50/50 I
think it would be incredible and just
the the hype that getting the whole
state of all and there's other states
obviously that are like that I mean you
could have the Bengals and the Browns
play horse about the horseshoe in Ohio
70 I think it would really be now they
always say well what about replay and
they have to be outfitted for an NFL you
mean come on dude if you're able to play
you know big-time college football games
at Penn State and Ohio State and Ann
Arbor I don't think it'd be that hard to
put an NFL game in there Ross I mean
they're already outfitted for replay at
Ohio State and it's already outfitted to
benefit the Ohio State players there I
saw personally for firsthand and they
were trying to measure a fourth down on
in overtime a couple years ago it's
order so all the Ohio State players and
the Browns and the Bengals would be
would be bent would love to play at the
Horseshoe for instant replay is this
thing on Brockman did that just go away
hey Ross great ideas love them all and
congrats on the preseason games with the
Eagles I got Malcolm Jenkins in studio
our number two you'll be calling his
preseason games this oh man I'm so fired
up about that and that's great you have
Malcolm he is totally beloved in
Philadelphia everything he's done for
that team in that community on and off
the field he is extremely impressive
yeah absolutely and I hope he's already
in our green room sir he heard that
broadside at his university institution
of learning Thank You Ross appreciate
you calling calling it to the show great
piece absolutely you got a radio calm
athletic as well as the Rost
her football podcast we're all podcasts
can be downloaded and her for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune to audience
channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app